I want to be respectful of my next guest
who's calling in to the Rich Eisen show
right now I'm going to remove the Rich
Eisen show mug which as you know it's a
very difficult thing for me to do
because I'm all about the branding there
is an iron-rich and Eisen and I'm a team
player on that front I'm gonna remove
that mug and place front and center my
bilf life mug that I received with the
men in Blazers crest on one side my bilf
life mug is placed directly in front of
me and the gentleman who provided me
with this bauble the co-host of men in
Blazers with his friend michael davies
our friend Roger Bennett back here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you ROG
oh I'm Rich Eisen better for hearing
your voice like the rest of America yes
yes what do you think of my mug that my
choice of mug gear Roger that's out of
respect for you and our follically
challenged experiences in life you're a
beautiful man we do say rich eyes and
boldness his truth boldness is truth
nation right up you're one of our
leaders we march behind you well
congrats on the return of the Premier
League sir
you must have been overjoyed to hear
that they were gonna give this a world
give it a go and it appears that despite
the lack of fans that everything went as
planned correct thank God
yes after a hundred day unplanned break
caused by the pandemic the greatest
global sporting telenovela the British
nation loves the English Premier League
of its pantheon of heroes and villains
is back yeah and you know the world was
watching including a bet rich every
single Commissioner out of every major
sports league in America to see how it
was it enough would it be enough with
this new fanless reality and it was
different to watch the players trot
around empty stadia there was definitely
from an American perspective less
theatrics
suddenly with no crowd to playful there
was no kind of rolling on the floor in
agony there was less celebrations the
players still trying to get real match
fit
to play at times with patchy and there
was fake crowd noise pumped in to the
broadcast there was a bit like an
Atlanta Falcons home game but it was
enough it was a manager Jurgen Klopp of
Liverpool Football Club who said that
when we were kids we grew up and fell in
love with the game and that game could
be at basketball
it could be gridiron football but he
went football soccer
he said we fell in love with the game
when we were kids and yes the spectacle
of pro sports has surpassed the game
with its theater but the game was enough
rich just to watch and be thrilled and
connected to that global conversation
again it was magnificent so I want to
get to the fan noise being pumped in in
a second because that absolutely
fascinates me and it is something that I
think even though you know people might
think tongue firmly planted in Chico I
think it is something that the NFL is
going to be taking a close look at as
other North American sports here what
about the results I know you're a never
Tony incorrect that's a correct
statement I am you're a remarkable man
so Everton I come from Liverpool which
is I football mad like Indiana high
school basketball Texas right football
everything I like the Mets of Liverpool
yes there is another team the Yankees
Liverpool League leaving Liverpool I am
cursed to walk the earth as a you know
Cleveland Browns fans will probably
relate to my suffering but yes go on
no but the result of that Everton placed
against Liverpool which had an
opportunity had they gotten past Everton
with a with a proper result or an
expected result and an opportunity to
wrap things up for the first time in 30
years with another win this week and yet
your your side stood in the way
correctly Everton odd it's a bit like I
guess urban war eagle to Liverpool's
Alabama Liverpool are a mighty team the
Easter when I was growing up win titles
by right I mean they weren't almost my
whole childhood was watching them bring
trophy after trophy back through the
city ever since then we've had our
moments
but not so much and what's remarkable is
Liverpool have not when their title in
thirty long years mercy fantastic years
some would say and then FSG Fenway
Sports Group the Boston Red Sox owners
brought Liverpool in October 2010 and it
took them a little time it wasn't Ethel
s but they got their head
John Henry and his team around the
unique competitive advantages some of
what which they've mastered with the Red
Sox in terms of identifying and
recruiting and scouting differently to
weather teams and they have year-on-year
over the past five or six years were
very remarkable leader a manager German
could Jurgen Klopp was like a Teutonic
Care Bear
he's like Jim Harbaugh in his enthusiasm
but he actually keeps winning and he is
led Liverpool to just six per five
points now from the title which is a
remarkable achievement the Red Sox 2004
achievement was you know breaking the
curse a remarkable sporting saying this
Liverpool achievement and it could
happen as soon as Wednesday when
Liverpool played Crystal Palace if the
results go the right way if FSG this
American ownership group can drag
Liverpool back to the promised land it
will be as Greater the sheave Minh as a
Red Sox but lived out with the whole
world watching and so huge huge respect
it's an incredible American achievement
in the global game the dulcet tones of
Roger Bennett here on the Rich Eisen
show co-host of men and blazers along
with our buddy Michael Davies right here
on the program so what else do we need
to know about this return he scored for
Chelsea and and and that's good news for
for all of us right writ large Roger
good news for the for America it's a
remarkable moment it's nice to feel good
about something even if it's just for a
minute you know Christine pelisek 21
year old from Hershey Pennsylvania who
moved to Chelsea Football Club and the
Premier League and this is his first
season he started poorly struggled and
then out of nowhere around October just
started scoring screen when you watch
him play plays a little bit like a point
guard
in the NBA just finding slivers of space
changing pace incredible burst of speed
and is able to mine crevices of space
and really hurt opponents he was then
injured has not played since January the
first of an adductor abductor strain and
what's remarkable is he came didn't stop
came into a game when his team were
one-nil down the weekend in the 55th
minute and within four minutes he made a
run to the far post jabbed the ball home
his seventh of the season and it was I'm
so happy for him and just the relief the
joy that he experienced you know
struggle then dazzled then fallen off
and now he's back contributing again
from an American football perspective
he's our Lord and Savior from a world
football perspective he's just another
young good player fighting for minutes
but it was a lovely moment and also at
the weekend a 17 year old from
Westchester New York gia Reina a
beautiful assist in the Bundesliga so
it's great from an American perspective
for a moment you know whatever religion
you are whatever Nyssa T whatever
political view you have the joy of
sports rich you can put it all aside for
a moment just connect feel wonderful
together and that's that's what
Christian political oudh us to do in the
weekend he's also a Salesman as well
he's trying to get he's trying to get me
on board for Chelsea I have right here
in front of me he sent me a note after I
talked about an MLS playoff game at
length on this program Roger he sent me
an autographed Chelsea Jersey right here
for me to hold up in a moment I guess
just like this to help promote the fact
that he's overseas and he's crushing it
it's great with it paired with the bills
life mug you should see it right now
Roger it is impressive to Joy there was
always a worry that this may be a
Frederick Rice kind of first year
he's shaking that he's not quite the
superstar that America demands but he's
doing amazing incredibly proud great
great reference to the dreadful New York
Knick nicknamed the French pastry by the
tabloid media great reference Roger
gosh that was fantastic let's get into
the crowd noise aspect of it because if
I'm not mistaken fans of the sport in
the UK have an ability to watch the
matches as as they're being played with
just nothing just the the au naturale
and then another where crowd noise is
being pumped in and controlled by who
who is the individual has this job Roger
can you find him and interview him on
men and blazers can you they using crowd
noises developed by our friends at EA
SPORTS FIFA a remarkable game where they
go every year to such incredible
detective lengths to almost track down
like musicologist every single chant
from every single stadium in every
single game so the it's a really through
the looking-glass moment where a game
which is based on a sport actually is
injecting itself to bring a reality to
the sport itself and it's needed you
know the Bundesliga came back first it
was the German Bundesliga the first
league back and the first game is a
massive one Dortmund against Schalke
don't you say two teams who were German
and everybody was watching the whole
world tuned in and it was like watching
a really good pickup game in the park
you could hear every single shout from
every single player the coaches
screaming when the the passes were here
had a that kind of rubbery ping that you
hear when you walk past a really good
game of pickup in the park when they
scored there was like a weird silence
just to ball him you'd hear the ripple
in the back of the net and instead of
that crowd noise that's theater that
epic moment of human poetry that is just
a delirious sporting moment you heard
nothing and it back then the players
were social distancing so they'd freeze
they'd run toward each other to hug each
other and celebrate and then three six
feet away from each other we have John
all
on our show and he said watching that
game it was like being in the worst
discotheque in Aunt worth watching their
gold celebrations just six men dancing
on their own and they realize they
needed fake crowd noise for the
broadcast just royal the blood to surge
and manipulate the emotion sport in the
end of the day rich is you know better
than I do it's just incredible human
theater and so the fake crowd noise is a
is a work in progress there's a one blow
fuse mixing it into the production it's
nearly there but it's enough off if your
watch enough sport you know every you
can know what you shut your eyes and
follow along with the game just by the
crowd ohs it's slightly off it's
slightly uncalibrated I think they
should just use the Seinfeld laugh track
instead for well have other special
effects why stop we've just fake sounds
like Godzilla rise above the stadium and
or a dragon sweeping over it and just to
signal halftime swooping over and
burning the place down I'm all for the
CGI when you're a little bit enriched it
should be all in I agree sound what do
you mean
Fox Sports has added sound forever we
had a sweetener behind us what for
sports well that's rich for what what
every sport we ever do highlights or is
to do for sweetening highlights come on
I thought you meant lives for one event
that was just recent we were talking
about C's what what I think we should do
Raj is I think though we should take
this a next level we should we should
let's do that I think they should pump
it in into the actual stadium then they
should act that that that home-field
advantage certainly in the NFL as its
coming like they should be able to
figure out what the average noise would
be for a certain moment in the game and
be allowed to pump it up and certainly
be allowed to in the Premier League
whatever chanting whatever is normally
happening in the stadium pump it in oh
the referee is a wine cup rich you want
you all know that - Roger that
yes I will say it's a controversial step
you know football is an intensely local
game in England and the fan base are so
loyal just generations and memories and
to watch football without those fans
there but with the fan noise you know it
raises questions for many of the fans I
why did we bother in the first place
though there are genuine fears that we
are we're all replaceable and to where
they have these English fans they zoom
them in they have you know 20 lucky fans
are zoomed into the school board and you
watching these kind of many of them
aging tattooed one-time hooligans
sitting suddenly in their living room
just completely be found as they watch
from afar you can tell they're itching
for a fight most of them and I just
watching these zoomed-in fans like
massive on the school board and I might
ice it's just the greatest risk in
sports I've ever seen this rich I know
their mentality and where you have the
first ever zoomed in Premier League fans
just the first ever Premier zoomed in
streakers going to be coming incredibly
better the two things in my mind go hand
in hand it was worth watching if only
for that America well they got that
needs to be vetted I'll have to agree we
should definitely we have to vet that
Roger I just love chatting with you man
love I miss it I miss it but I'm a
little bit that that the Premier League
is back on it on NBCSN NBC Sports and
more and men in Blazers you've got
something to talk about which so many
people need and you're so great talking
about it rich it is it's that global
conversation that connectivity that no
matter what you're feeling in that
moment hi although we can all be
connected to the same thing for 90
minutes that most important least
important thing that's what's wonderful
and so are you it's a joy to be with you
again the greatest mention the sports
business to you and your family you say
no you Roger Thank You same to you at
ROG Bennett with the two ends two T's on
Twitter like the ground you guys
Roger in it there is hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here